what's the difference between a garden and a jungle?
a garden's a nice place
where civilized human beings walk around.
a jungle is the heart of darkness
and where wild animals live.
now, many people in Africa, Asia,
Latin America remember very well how,
in the name of civilization,
European colonialism treated them like wild animals,
enslaving them,
torturing them
and even exhibiting them in human zoos. therefore,
when the highest diplomat of the European Union
compares Europe to a garden,
but especially the rest of the world to a jungle,
the message these people here
is that Europe is still driven by neo colonialism,
we cannot let that message pause.